To create our histogram of user ages, let's start by using
the Q plot function. We'll pass it the variable age. And our
data set is pseudo Facebook so PF. And I'm going to add
some color using the color and fill parameters. Running this code we
see we get our histogram. Now you might have tried a variety
of bin widths. And in this case I think a bin width
of one is the best. So let's add that in here. I
chose a bin width of one since, one makes sense, since we're
going by years or ages. This gives me a histogram of
counts of users by individual years, so I can get a
finer view of the data for say, like, 25 years old.
By setting the bin width equal to one, it allows us
to more easily spot unusual spikes in our data. Points like
here, here, and definitely out here. Let's zoom in on this
plot and take a closer look. I see the largest spikes
in the mid to late 20's. And we don't have any users
who put in an age lower than 13 at the left
of the histogram. This makes sense because users must be at least
13 years old to set up a Facebook account. Now there's also
some unusual spikes above 100, but my guess is that some users
may be exaggerating their age. Do you have any friends who that
are 100 years or older on Facebook? I know I certainly don't.
And one final comment that I want to make is that your x-axis
might look slightly different than mine. Remember that we can use scale
x discrete or scale x continuous to change this appearance.
So I adding scale x discrete here, I can set the
breaks so they run from 0 to 113, and they
increment every five units, or every five years. Now you might
be wondering why I chose 113 here, and I have
a simple answer for you. I just used the maximum age
in our user data set. Remember I can find that
out by running Summary on that variable. So I can see
the minimum age is 13, and the maximum age is 113.